Kourtney Kardashian celebrates her
one-year Vegas wedding anniversary to
Travis Barker it's a beautiful thing but
Court's big day of turning up nearly
ended with throwing up I was a hot slob
Kebab the Kardashian star dropped a few
behind the scenes snaps from their Sin
City nuptials including these Sweet
pda-filled Moments what could be a more
fun night in Vegas but then there's this
shot that may have come after some shots
of the hard stuff court on the floor of
a car with trout holding her hand she
admits in the caption she had way too
much tequila at the chapel and adds
quote yes that's me about to throw up
I'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens did you walk down the
aisle yes I can please tell me your
videos but I've blacked out I actually
don't remember though
[Music]
I'm like slurring if you can't hear well
despite almost puking Courtney says it
was one of the best nights of Our Lives
I am truly living my best life
don't let anyone tell you any different
is that anything like our real wedding
will be really silly oh because it was
awesome it was so fun
the crevice love is so real it had to be
celebrated three separate times in Vegas
in Santa Barbara and across the pond
this is our personal archive footage
that we are sharing with the world yeah
we'll get a peek at the European
festivities in the Hulu special till
death do us part Courtney and Travis
airing April 13th we'll see rare footage
of the couple tying the knot in front of
their close friends and family in
Portofino Italy I just felt like I'm
about to marry like the love of my life
and then it was like oh my God I'm about
to marry the love of my life and then it
all set in
we provided the feeling and the vibe and
then really trusted Dominico to like
carry it out we wanted it to feel
authentic
three weddings later it seems court and
trapped or happier than ever our wedding
felt like time didn't exist and it just
felt perfect
foreign